[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to lobby
gave spots a weekly video game hangout
here in San Francisco
every Wednesday I'm your host Mike my
heart here as always with reviews at our
Peter Brown hey Rob handler hi and
that's not Kelly pluggy that's Jake
Decker I'm not Kelly she is not feeling
well today she's also had a crazy couple
weeks so she just either working from
home or just resting
she finished destiny she finished
Wolfenstein she's gonna take it easy
so we brought Jake on who's been playing
all these games we're gonna talk about
and you kept up with the Paris games
week announcements which we're also
gonna dive into a lot of that stuff came
out this week actually just when we
thought just when I thought I had a
handle on games Sony dropped in other
news deuce on us as I like to say
talking about house mark that's not Sony
but no no actually you buy that before
the show so now you got an out today the
press conference I would go to an email
that said arcade is dead from house mark
the developers of resogun ex machina
matter fall Super Stardust HD and
they're basically like thanks for
joining us making all these games and
playing them over the years it's been a
lot of fun but enough of you not enough
of you spent money and bought them
actually you got them through free
services and that's nice but it doesn't
keep a business alive so we're changing
directions and that sucks cuz those are
all most of those were really good games
yeah
I'd say they're very least like I say
matter fall was maybe the most
underwhelming one but it was still
pretty decent right yeah yeah
underwhelming for them but so good damn
yeah it sucks we'll see what they do
next maybe something super unexpected
and cool yeah hopefully their talents
prove useful elsewhere I'm sure they
will we do have a most the news today is
the Paris games week mainly the Sony
exclusives that they announced or
upcoming stuff I think they're close
this one now is Shadow the Colossus
which is awesome we might touch on
stranger things season 2 but we also
have a full show so we might not because
that's also like heavy spoiler territory
and I don't want to talk about something
we can't really spoil then we can also
go deeper into Wolfenstein 2 what makes
it such a good shooter and what makes
Super Mario Odyssey an essential 10 out
of 10 here at games well that's right
yeah and you through a you through a
DEA's on that game I did throw a DS
we'll talk about that more we also have
a giveaway we'll talk about that later
in the show and we have another
announcement some GameSpot faithful are
probably waiting for us to talk a little
bit about extra life I mean I go I might
as well just talk about it now and I'll
reiterate the end of the show for those
who don't know extra life the gaming
marathon it's usually a 24-hour marathon
but
the it's essentially we play games for a
long time and we donate all the money to
sick kids there's a very terrible photo
let's see oh thanks
someone found that anyway we do 72 hours
starting this year November 17th Friday
at noon we're gonna start playing and
then for those of you who were here last
year in the year before that we hand off
the UK team we hand off to the Australia
team and we do 72 hours total
I believe we end up back here at noon on
Monday that's correct or we might don't
think we end here but we'll be back here
before it ends 72 hours total will be
playing sonic games we'll be streaming
the whole thing on Twitch presumably
YouTube and GameSpot obviously games my
fans can join us and make us do really
terrible stuff for donations including
eating some weird confections that
people mix up Nick margarita got alright
can we cut away so it'll be fun and I
know people were waiting for that so
November 17th new in Pacific time will
be starting we are having a meeting
later today so we'll know which like
major games are gonna play other than
that we're always open to the audience
suggestions and I'll reiterate it again
at the end of the show for people who
are not here now but as usual if you're
here on Twitch or YouTube or GameSpot
thank you for joining in the chats and
I'll be monitoring those the whole time
we have some questions on Twitter about
all the games that came out and all the
Sony exclusives that got announced but
let's dive into it man
not a Sony exclusive but the destiny -
curse of Osiris expansion the first one
for Bungie sequel is releasing December
5th got a release date are you guys
excited for this it's about time yeah
yeah well you've been super into destiny
- well compared to the first game right
yeah and I feel like I've exhausted my
interest in it so while I am joking I
mean it's pretty quick for an expansion
I feel I do kind of I'm glad to see it's
coming soon yeah cuz I'd like to keep
playing the game but right now it's not
giving me a reason to you John Luke he
was saying I was asking is this kind of
the same timeframe that the dark below
expansion came out for the first game I
actually think it kind of was they kind
of get right on this I mean it makes
sense they're trying to keep people
invest in this game I have not played
much of destiny - unfortunately but I
think more people in the office have
been playing destiny - then played
destiny one at the beginning
Jake a robber you too Jake are you still
in on destiny too or no I I kind of
tapered off but that was mostly because
you know Wolfenstein Mario Assassin's
Creed all came out the same day so I
kind of had to but I was kind of getting
getting tired of the grind but this does
kind of reignite that fuse I'd say I'll
probably play it I have the season pass
so I might as well oh right yeah cuz the
limited edition whatever his called came
with it yeah
robbed beautifully you played a lot of
destiny too right I played a lot but
absolutely fell off in in that there
were just other things to do we're lucky
enough to like have so many games to
cover but at the same time like I just I
don't know there were other things I
needed to play you know but I don't know
that trailer kind of looked really se me
yeah it does you know I mean but like
I'm not one to like point that destiny
stuff cuz I just don't know a game and I
don't know what to expect I guess out of
an expansion cuz I never really played
the first game long enough to I would
need to see like a spreadsheet of here's
all the new gear and ya know right at a
glance it's really hard to tell yeah I
would say don't expect like a taken king
level of a revamping I would say I think
it enemy types from what I understand
it's gonna be more just more of the same
but just more rather than like taking
Kane came back and actually reworked how
destiny worked I don't think they need
to do that yet yeah I don't obviously
destiny to is not and in as shaky as a
spot as destiny one was at this point I
think I think they figured out a lot of
the kinks to probably improve it in the
future but as far as actual like quality
of life and structural changes I don't
know that there's gonna be a lot with
was a cursive Osiris but yeah that's
December 5th and we'll have more leading
up to that I believe there's a event
next week in Bellevue that were Bundy's
gracious enough to be inviting us to so
we'll be checking that out that that
character Osiris is a big deal though
right yeah he's like he's in like I
don't know I just I feel like of the of
the lore and stuff that I've looked into
like the guy like has been like how
floating around yeah like there's like
the plains of Osiris was a thing or am I
just making up a cool landscape he's a
warlock that went like kind of crazy
right like too extreme or something like
went rogue when Troy I don't know
probably not sounds right III don't like
his helmet yeah or is like yeah all
right Annie way that's December 5th will
spider-man we saw more of this from
insomniac they showed off more Miles
Morales he'll be playing spider-man this
time around wait will he be is it
there's no Miles Morales was in the
trailer
but anyway insomniac showed off its
spider-man a quarter one quarter to
still in 2018
you guys said this was mainly cinematics
from what you watched I kept I got up on
this afterward it's a very superficial
assessment but it's giving me strong
quantum break vibes and I don't like man
and I need to see a whole lot more
continuous gameplay like uncut before I
can get real excited about this I agree
I think though I mean insomniac though
is usually pretty good about gameplay
they are no totally um
so I'm not super worried about that but
yeah it is kind of weird that we still
haven't seen an extended set of gameplay
series of gameplay where I use the
combat that I've seen yeah yeah yeah I
guess the combat is more worrisome than
the movement I think the movement will
be sure pretty good the e3 I mean that
was the last thing they showed me three
right there the the long like kind of
rooftop combat stretch yeah but it looks
good it was but it was a lot of that
like you know contextual zipping back
and forth automatically across groups of
people Arkham
I personally just I just don't any
interest in that style of combat it's
it's - it strips we have like what I
feel like is my own accomplishments
didn't I saw a headline today - that you
will be able to play as Mary Jane as
well sick so that's all in this trailer
kind of hitting it hinted at that they
had like a weird kind of like weird like
weird kind of like pan and like it
totally seemed like a third-person Mary
Jane Mary Jane I like you I know what I
was implying like what could you do with
her would you expect I don't walk with a
serious fight crime I don't know upside
down okay sorry I believe you are Peter
Parker but Miles Morales factors into
this
who the heck in himself Miles Morales is
another person that plays spider-man he
was in the accusing the trailer with
Peter Parker in this sacrilegious yeah I
don't know I fell off of spider-man
when was that everything in the comics
yeah okay
do you not read spider-man comics I did
not neither do I so that is just quarter
one quarter to next year from insomniac
I like most of stuff insomniac does and
what like you guys said it wasn't even
just the combat it was the traveling
through the city and all of the actual
it was all contextual kind of like it
seemed way too choreographed and I want
to be able to improvise a Spider Man you
guys play spider-man - yeah I did yeah
that's a fair point like that I
definitely want to see the more like
free roaming right yeah but it looked
cool like to see in again when referring
to the e3 trailer of like his webbing
actually locking onto like tangible
things you know I post those other games
I remember you said you mentioned
spider-man 2 and that one you actually
had to attach to buildings but I think
spider-man 3 right after was like a huge
downgrade and you're just like swinging
on air and like yeah alright there's a
Dan coming stand up bit rays like what
happens like when spider-man's out in
the open like in like a field there's a
good one building in town and like
Midwest Superman kick his ass there I
don't like Superman anyways I think
Superman kick his ass anyway no not the
Kryptonite involved didn't you don't you
know anything the Hong Kong Massacre
top-down
sorry yeah top-down twin-stick shooters
you guys see anything from that smaller
indie game that they showed off
yesterday I saw once described people
are people are describing it as Max
Payne mixed with hotline Miami but
everything's hotline Miami these days
the spider-man is hotline Miami mixed
with Batman ah but anyway this is the
Hong Kong massacre we're seeing here I
kind of I don't know much about it
outside of the fact that it's a top-down
twin-stick shooter looks like a little
noir setting it could be cool if the
story really works otherwise I'm not
interested yeah how many games we got
like this it's a very first game from an
independent two person studio in Sweden
called risky if I'm pronouncing that
correctly but it was first revealed in
2014
being built from the ground up in unity
so see what happens with this but they
do have a development blog where they're
kind of talking about hunting down the
leader of a Japanese gang in modern-day
Hong Kong
they also showed off the gardens between
which is another smaller indie game
according to our news news story -
captain toad like ps4 puzzler called the
gardens between yeah this looks pretty
interesting apart from being you know a
sensitive game or game for sensitive
teenagers or people like me who wish I
was still teenager what else is new
isn't it weird how I didn't like a weird
number of serial killers end up having
catching the Rye next to their bed or
something they read all the time there's
no I don't know if that's an urban myth
or if that's true well I read that I
don't think this looks like a really
sweet game that's got a really you know
solid aesthetic going on and the captain
toad stuff seems to be related to the
fact that like you know you're not
bounding all over the place and doing
these really crazy actions or using your
environment to get places and yeah solve
puzzles so art direction kind of looks
like rhyme a little bit maybe that's
just the cell shade mm-hmm yeah like
oxen freeze sort of concept art or
what's the game recently it's like XCOM
with Oregon Trail on when you're going
out land not out of the land that's
something else it's not it over oh thank
you yes it was an O risky game title
stuck but also we saw more of David
cages Detroit become human I put this at
the top of a list of games I don't
really care about but they show it off
more of it a lot of people are wondering
if David cage is gonna be able to pull
off the whole abusive father thing so
let me get this straight like based on
this trailer is she made in the image of
his former wife who left them that's
what you kind of what seems to our
unravel know which the daughter shows a
picture of basically you know if you're
playing it as this like Android mmm
her head decapitated saying this is what
happened you you don't remember because
you just got white this this was the
first trailer I think that I mean of the
trailers have shown that really kind of
rub me into interests like
this seems really that was so horrible
those words I just lined up but we're
gonna ignore that but it seems really
heavy yeah what's going on anything but
the gameplay I still don't understand
like it's just pick a choice I got
choose-your-own-adventure he's like
green so far that's what's kind of
frustrating then is because like are all
these scenes then just like have you
played a David cage game before maybe
that's the correct way to surpass
conversation have telltale ish sort of
right like are they are they implying
that there's heavy replayability like is
this something that like I'm expected to
like play again and again its
reliability is one aspect it's more that
the game is it can flex to whatever you
would like to do so it's it's more or
less that it's a story that's got a
beginning in an ending but you can kind
of you know get through it in your own
way more or less and always sort of be
able to exercise something different
it's also weird that every time they've
shown it at a show it's been an almost a
completely different set of characters
and environment last time yeah it sounds
stupid because the actor that they used
in it it would show the actual like
replicant uprising in the city
it was the actor from Cabin in the Woods
who plays the smart archetype he's in
other stuff too much really
no no that's I don't use a weird
reference that's why I'm confused
I mean heavy rain too had multiple
character so I would be surprised if
that's something that maybe they'll
cause again to be honest like I I'm
interested in this game yeah like I know
a lot of people like to hate on david
cage and sometimes rightfully so like i
don't think he is the best at handling
some of these serious topics and themes
but that being said like i'm willing to
give it a shot like the presentation i
think is looks great and i I really
liked heavy rain
did you like beyond I enjoyed beyond I
didn't think it sucked like a lot of
people thought I I had fun with it
but I remember that when the first
trailer came out that like they're like
oh she's part of the CIA
and that was when it all disappeared I
don't remember I didn't
pay attention to it much it's a I think
we have to address kind of a little bit
of controversy leads to discussion
around this yeah yeah cuz like right now
everyone's really upset because okay
it shows abuse and uses that as sort of
like the fulcrum for like this scene and
everyone's very wary of the fact that
David cage might not really be able to
handle this and like everyone's saying
you know let's give him a shot like
that's fair we do need to see this in
context but he there's a bunch of
interviews that went out yesterday and
he could not for the life of him give a
solid explanation as to why he has to
use child abuse and abuse against women
to get his story across he goes it's a
heavy theme you're like right but why
that why that specifically he's because
I wanted something emotional then his
other defense was always like would you
be asking a film director the same thing
right yeah and they would probably have
an answer is right they're using it
exactly so I you know I think that
people are up in arms about this quite a
bit because David cage is a really kind
of crappy track record when it comes to
this sort of stuff and would it be that
surprising to see him fumble this one
again no will he I don't know maybe he's
learned from his lessons he doesn't know
how to interview properly but yeah it
wasn't also like oh I just think that
like the novelty of some of his older
games kind of kind of masks that sort of
poor not poor writing but it kind of
masked some of those weaknesses and I
think now that it's so realistic and
people are kind of used to like the
whole David cage stick like I we know it
this next David cage game is gonna be
now people are a little more paying
attention to the writing and the
storytelling and how that works and yeah
and what's actually trying to exactly I
don't know if you'll be able to pull
that off but I'm curious definitely
curious yeah it's uh I wish I could just
explain it a little bit better yeah it's
not the only trailer that was kind of
brutal but I guess we'll get to that
later just a mouth they're off the order
the b-roll uh Jake and Rob I'm not doing
this to call you out I'm actually very
excited for you to you have not played
Shi out of the Colossus February 6 2018
you'll be able to play it on ps4
BluePoint whoo Pete you were talking
about them a lot yesterday poor studio
that did some great remakes walk me
through them they did titanfall on Xbox
360 they did the Metal Gear Solid Legacy
Collection among no you helped me out
because I forgot already the gravity
rush free man
to PlayStation 4 that did the one of the
God of War collections they did the Eco
and Shadow of the Colossus ps3 remasters
and that was more of a port compared to
this right yeah yeah this a that's a
slight remaster this is a full-on remake
you know outside of the concepts and
what the game is actually having you do
pretty much all the assets and systems
and interaction and stuff like that
seems to be just remade completely it's
2008 I don't know I bet the Year
if--like the game released game 2005 I
believe 2005 ps3 you must have been what
2009 10 or something maybe a little
after that but yeah the game was
originally 2005 unless I'm grossly
mistaken I can look that up but yeah you
guys so you don't even know someone like
the story stuff and I'm not gonna talk
about it at all because good it's a very
minimalist story but there it's it's
effective but you know the idea of the
game it's just 16 huge bosses varying
sizes and stuff and why'd you say 16
world well that's a spoiler dude sorry I
know you guys I'm assuming you'll after
everything you've heard you'll be
interested in playing this on February
6th yeah I liked yesterday we were like
chatting about it because this trailer
actually was really impressive to me
like for a game that old right like the
hair texture we have some gameplay over
the shoulder or off off screen gameplay
that I believe Adam from UK took but
like it's still you can still tell how
the quality is like surreal like I don't
know like just the hate for a game
that's old like the hair on these bosses
all done though that's yeah like - same
for game this old that actually doesn't
matter this was all redone yeah this
right here the footage we're seeing is
pits redone it's not just ported like
what is it so what has redone exactly
mean then like they say they they
literally like shoved the table clean
and like yes yes they also rework raisi
the part that I'm really excited for is
that they actually they've been saying
they rework the controls a little bit
which the controls themselves were
always kind of intuitive but they're
always a little bit janky and clunky in
my opinion at least like the main
character his name is escaping right now
his horses agro his name will come back
to me it always does he it was he was
kind of floaty
when he's climbing it was almost like I
mean you it's very much based on your
grip you have an endurance meter kind of
where you're climbing these colossi and
if you lose your grip you fall off
obviously but and you know it's about
stabbing weak points and shooting with
your bow but it's very much it was
always kind of loose but they said
they're reworking a lot of it to
actually feel better that's the same on
these uh with these new controls
yesterday we had a Paris games week
event here and I got to check it out and
yeah I've never played it but it looked
fantastic orgeous like I'm so excited
for this yeah
so that's essentially what the studio
does is just like from the ground up so
this is the first time they're doing
that okay
in the past they had mostly done
remastering importing so for like the
middle your solid HD collection you
would have seen them like yes port the
games a little bit then also remaster
some of the graphics which means taking
old textures and updating them or you
know essentially doing a high-res copy
there's a lot of that going into this
like they're using the original
like source material but not necessarily
the original assets so everything will
bear the same identity that it had back
then but the actual assets they're using
in game as far as I'm aware are all
created from scratch how how can you how
can they are like I mean this game is
really great people like seem to praise
about this game but I just find that
like kind of fascinating like as far as
like the budget like involved right like
that's more work yeah to do something
like this like how how do you how does a
studio like argue for that I guess like
it's just based on the fact that this
game is just so renowned well I mean
Sony's in control and Sony's a platform
holder and they'll always do what they
can to get the upper hand even if it
means spending an extra dime so I'm sure
that they told Blue Point we'd like the
work you do we want you to apply that to
a game that we already love but we just
want you to make it feel fresh not just
updated but okay his name's wander by
the way yes and Japan the name of game
is wonder the Colossus yeah but it's
Foom 800 we Ada and my people
mispronounce it wait does enough go away
- did Last Guardian oh yeah which I
didn't personally like as much as this
or eco I know I know most people like
the Last Guardian but still I'd say this
no I don't wanna talk about stories but
here this is the first Colossus you
fight
but it's awesome like I mean I was
chatting with John Luke a lot yesterday
everybody has like their favorite
Colossus that they remember these are
it's just a boss rush but yeah that's so
reductive to say because it's also in
this like super lonely world it's
massive you know like you hold your
sword up to find out where to go next
well and most of the bosses are
essentially levels in and of themselves
yeah you climb on their bodies there's a
yeah exactly
there's been a few games that have tried
to mimic this like I'd say maybe the
most notable unless I'm forgetting
something is something like castlevania
lords of Shadow the first one had a
bunch of bosses that incorporated it and
it was a great game and those I thought
and those boss spells are pretty good
but it's not something you see mimic
very often elsewhere which is kind of
too bad because it's a really neat
concept but just kind of goes to show
like how impressive this game was and
probably will continue to be especially
for people who've never played it before
I remember god of war yeah we tried to
do that God of War 2 came out like right
after shadow classes I believe and then
God for three lay around but those were
more it wasn't there wasn't as much
agency involved it would be like those
QuickTime events that God of War is so
pervasive and you'd be climbing up
fighting Poseidon on a Titan I forget at
the beginning of three and then a
beginning of two you're fighting the
Colossus of Rhodes Oh interesting enough
Colossus but yeah it was it was just a
massive scale Boston like some of the
bosses in Sheva Colossus I think later
on the game the average time it will
take you a beat some of them is like 40
minutes yeah what's up there yeah the
whole game is as boss fights but
technically but like pizza that's there
very much levels unto themselves but I
forget what the final boss takes it can
take upwards of an hour once when you're
figuring it out this is different
because there's let's say stages so you
get thrown off and then there's like a
stage to type things shell breaks SCAF
right there and then first I played I
didn't even know you could find those
lizards that upgrade your health
in the world right yeah I just did it
without those but anyway yeah this game
is fantastic
I hesitate to even call it a cult
classic although I think it is but I
think it's sold better than that like -
well to be called a cult classic it's
fantastic I'm excited that you guys
don't really know much about like what
happens in the game cuz that's I would
I'm very jealous that you're going into
a fresh and do everything power to keep
it that way yeah and I'm glad you guys
there are a couple things I said
yesterday like oh she he's carrying
around this
and you guys and you guys were just like
silent I was like okay I'll stop yeah
yeah or whatever her role as Yoda Yoda
February 6th 2018 next year uh a game
that kind of piqued my interest and a
few other people concrete geni kind of a
little more like angsty stuff he finds a
match paintbrush and his illustrations
come to life in these back alleys it
kind of the idea of it reminded me a
little bit of dreams in terms of like
using your own creativity but this seems
much more story-driven and not as like
just based on what you want to happen in
the world obviously dreams being that
psvr game but this looks super cool yeah
did you guys watch this whole oh yeah
yeah it seems really neat like yeah the
the drawing s6 yeah it looks really good
our art styles gray like kind of like
the combination of like kind of like
stop animation yeah like it reminds me
of like those Coraline and was the cube
oh kuba kuba kuba on the two strings yes
that kuba no thinking it's that stop
animation style is inserting but yeah
the drawing looks fun got it like this
this looks really fun like as far as I
mean I also wonder like how how much of
like your own like creative impact do
these drawings have like he's funny are
the Styles all the same like I don't
know like IB I'd be interested to see
like different people's art if that's
something like simple convenient yeah
like something to compare to you like
all I drew this is how different is this
compared to you like are these more
linear based like drawings like I don't
know Mike how much does it constrain you
yeah part puzzle part action platformer
so that kind of leads me to believe it
won't be just free reign and there's the
story of you fighting back against these
bullies and these back alleys of a town
called Ensco I don't know if it's
supposed to be modeled after a certain
region it seems like you're in Europe or
something seems like this town is empty
except for those bullies the only one
nothing he found a magic what do you
think I'm imagining in this town you
couldn't have given me a gun here's a it
looks very very cool it looks gorgeous
and I'm looking forward to seeing more
from that and I'm looking forward to
hopefully in the end these drawings bust
out of the of the walls and believe I
gotta go so so an interesting little
tidbit I found this on and gadget the
creative director Dominick Roby yard
creative director of Sony studio pixel
opus his first gig in videogames was
testing Jet Set Radio and he said the
artwork of that heavily inspired this or
at least the idea of that game the art
direction kind of bled into this a
little bit yeah
cool something I'm super excited about
spelunky dos got announced as well
didn't really see much gameplay if any I
think it was all just these photos
showing like apparently the network
generation of people going seeking after
Yuma or whatever but yeah obviously like
spelunky itself is kind of I would say
was in the early one of the early games
in that wave that was kind of
repopulating roguelikes procedural
generation obviously like it's
platforming hardcore kind of 2d that dog
was drinking out of a skull yeah I'm
really curious what they're gonna do to
iterate on the first one because I mean
obviously we didn't see anything but I I
can't like when I play that game it's
not like there wasn't anything when I
was like I wish they did this I wish
they did this like like I love that game
and I think it's I don't to say perfect
but I think it is one of the most like
pure sort of roguelikes I've played
there's not much I could say you could
do that game yeah like I'm cute like
they kind of hinted it going to the sky
like so I'm like okay so maybe it's like
the same thing but in space different
ways that ik yeah like I don't know how
much is gonna change or how much really
needs to change to be honest even just
now on like the logo itself the title
screen shows the moon behind it you have
no idea maybe instead of yet going down
you're going up too so that's kinda what
I'm thinking like different enemies
different likes gravity yeah last time I
played you were watching I got killed by
the shopkeeper like a guy
damn casual did you steal from him I
mean I accidentally whipped him when I
was I was trying to move the teleporter
out from behind the freeze ray or
whatever and I finally whipped him and
he shocked on me in the face didn't go
well I love that game though it's very
good yeah so Blanca - I don't believe
has any release dates or anything and
now it's for ps4 just ps4 right yeah
right now as of now PC and ps4 first
trailer came out but coming first to ps4
and Steam no other platforms have yet
been mentioned with the original came to
numerous systems and the use of it first
suggests it might be like a console time
exclusive cool I'm really excited for
that we also have guacamelee - yeah
lunch box the first one super likely I'd
like you know like Mexican luchador
aesthetic storyline but also it's a
Metroidvania game kind of but with a
little more involved combat with combos
and everything you can get very vibrant
dia de los muertos aesthetic and
everything and the first one was great I
loved it I have too many memes for my
white hair but overall that game was
really much very awesome super good had
cool times
no crack on melee - I didn't did they
show game playing this or is it all they
showed a bunch of gameplay Michael
really yeah was it just look good just
look does it look different at all no it
doesn't look like the first if you
showed me this I would say oh that's
guacamelee yeah I could have done with a
new character instead of this the
luchador looted whatever his name is I
forget his name yeah it's a small thing
but just seeing the same character over
again and at least in the format of a
trailer I'm like I wish there was
something I could point to you the
four-player local co-op support now
right and also you could turn into a
chicken that was like the big crux to
this trailer at least they're trying to
sell this new chicken - bill are you
sure you can really transform into a
chicken in the first one yes you can
transform instead of turning into the
ball like in samus metroid you turn - oh
how much money do you want to bet money
how are your stories wrong then whoever
wrote this I'm gonna call him out you
out Rob you and Chris Pereira have to
duke it out because he said it's a new
ability
crispy I don't know guacamelee seven
years after the original story Juan I
got that day is living a happy life his
family when his friend and trainer who I
Chivo discovers a new evil menace that
threatens to destroy not only Mexico but
time and space itself that'd be awesome
just came to switch not just it probably
really probably will yeah make sense i I
love the first one I thought it was
fantastic but it came out at a time
where there weren't like a ton of
Metroidvania --nz I feel like now
they've been so many every time I
checked steam there's like five new
Metroidvania x' so i'm curious how much
time i'll actually want to spend playing
this especially after like Samus Returns
which I thought was fantastic I feel
like it's the personality in the combat
there that's true so the combat
definitely I thought was a lot of funny
on the personality but I don't know
maybe I'm getting sick of Metroidvania
Zarek green friend of the show said
consider me rubbed to interest Jake
you've been waiting for this last most
part to another the second trailer I
would say yeah the first role and the
after she kill those people in the house
this one was just a whole new set of
characters right there wasn't anybody
that we know in fact like when they
first started a bunch of us were like is
this dais gone because and but then like
the old like this is this looks too good
to not be naughty done enough bikers
yeah yeah that too yeah so Jake walk
through what was happening here this
this describe this trailer definitely
also drew some controversy we can get to
that but what happened here so I only
watch this trailer once unlike the first
one which I watched probably dozen times
but I mean essentially it seems like
some a cultish group or something is
carrying a woman and they're basically
about to kill her
and also other people hanging off the
trees there's other people hanging off
the trees and then seems like some other
faction comes and saves them and they're
debating whether or not they should save
her yeah they said she's she's one of
them so but it was like the two people
who were almost saving her the second
girl they bring in they were apparently
part of the same faction there were two
younger kids right yeah they're like
teenagers maybe a little older
shaved yes Sarah Connor though it does
yeah she's jacked yes yeah this is
pretty brutal and then yeah this is
definitely Jake you said you watched it
once I think I could only watch it once
it was really intense
I met hammer the take off her wings
screw that
yeah it was hard to watch I hate stuff
like you knew it had to be Naughty Dog
like what Justin was saying then like
this is clearly not a dog it looks too
good but I mean honestly there was
nothing that really pointed it to last
us until that and sort of yeah her nose
I was waiting for like a firefly tattoo
or something to show that's why they
yeah I figured you'd see that on at
least one of them it's definitely a
cultish though because things they were
saying they're saying like clipper wings
and also yeah and all the people hanging
have their guts cut out so it seems
they're definitely some sort of
religious inclination to it I never buy
scenes like this in movies where like
the villain is about to kill someone
like there's a noise and they're like
I'm gonna stop what I was doing that
I've been trying to do for months just
to turn around and look at what's
happening i belly as much as i love
demons thrones i think right here game
thrones does something like that every
episode is just like this person is
clearly not gonna I mean well that shows
not afraid to kill people or I think it
was too heavily on it but there's so
many times it's like oh this third party
came in to save the day at the last
second when they were raised the sword
above them yeah they showed this whole
thing there's a TV there so the
controversy around this was that it was
it was just I mean obviously really
brutal but that's one thing obviously
the Last of Us was brutal and if they're
going for like a Cormac McCarthy vibe
but another thing was everybody noticed
like all the violence is you aside from
that dude getting Shawn the face is
being done to women I think the bigger
problem here it goes back to the at
least in my opinion and Idon't up a
little the second point but the if
Naughty Dog is trying to and just Sony
in particular is trying to show what the
last of us to is really all about and
all they show is this this trailer just
about uber violence and torture and
death like yes those are central things
in the Last of Us - but that is just
like it that's a really unfortunate way
to have to like bottle an entire game is
with something like this and I think
people are just upset like why why does
it always have
to be just uber violence that we look to
as what makes a game interesting like if
I saw a trailer for just this and
someone advertised last of us to I would
say I don't really feel like playing
that yeah that that doesn't seem like my
sort of experience it's like torture and
death like and and that there's some of
that [ __ ] in the real world I don't
write and and not clearly establish like
sides right like the fact that we can't
point like there's three parties I guess
so tack it like we don't know anything
else and I it's just violence for this
at this point good today you can maybe
assume that the girl that was being hung
was one of the people and she betrayed
them or something because they said one
of them I have no idea or like if there
are more le types right like if is that
now the world where there's like a
separation of like who can be infected
who can't
yeah that's where my mind went but like
yeah I mean Jackie said I only watch it
once yeah this is not a trailer I want
to like dissect to go back I think it's
pretty haunting to Peter's point like if
I didn't know this was the last of us I
probably wouldn't be super interested in
this game because it is it's a lot it's
a lot but I mean it is it is Naughty Dog
so I have faith that they will tell a
very tight story that I mean it's like
the opposite of sort of what we saw with
David cage right it's kind of like I
don't know if you're gonna be able to
pull this off but with Naughty Dog I'm
more than confident that they have the
chops to pull the story like this off
but yeah like I and plus I'd kind of
rather see Joel and Ellie and I
understand why they're not showing it
maybe just to add suspense hold off on
that but still it was like I don't know
these characters I don't really care I
don't know how this helps advance the
messaging around their game I mean we're
talking about it but it's not like we're
sitting here like a hundred percent
positive like it's created this sort of
like weird talking point around it yeah
yeah I'm you know I'm stoked for the
second trailer they haven't really
announced when that's gonna happen
presumably next year last was part two
looking for is that love The Last of Us
you haven't played that go play that I
to more games I want to talk about
before we get to Mario and Wolfenstein
to
Sony showed off or announced first off
god of war from we to e3s ago they first
showed this and they shifted from Greek
mythology to Norse presumably kratos
kind of a father-son story going on I'm
still super unclear we were even talking
about this right before the show is this
the same timeline and storyline as when
he was fighting Greek gods and
everything and he was the God of War or
is this separate they're just using his
likeness again because it's all Norse
mythology and like maybe like a Ragnarok
thing Allah help laid which there's more
than one comparison to that that I would
make but I don't know what you guys
think this trailer Jake you were saying
kratos is kind of a shitty dad that was
my thing yeah let's bring his son on
this this [ __ ] help me fight these
undead creatures that seem to explode in
the lava and then he just like shames
him for not being able to kill a Titan
right away Cyclops or whatever but yeah
I was saying it's kind of an odd before
I played hell blade I was a little bit
concerned it was kind of having trouble
wrapping my head around the idea of a
fixed camera third-person melee game
because obviously the older got upwards
more like devil may cry or lords of
shadow in that there were kind of
character action free-roaming Bayonetta
kind of camera third-person action games
or as this looks like hell blade it's
like over the shoulder and before he'll
blade I didn't think it could be done
well he'll blades combat looks a lot
more vanilla-based compared to God of
War but I looked for they showed off
that actually more powers than this one
so it looks like it could be cool I
don't know everything they're showing
about this arena does really surprise me
at all yeah did you like the God of War
games back in the day like one and two
and then three I was like it was pretty
rad but one into that looked a huge
impression I mean I think inspired a lot
of the industry to kind of like figure
out how to be blockbuster and creative
you know all in one kind of package and
super impressive series from the past I
I'm not really sure where it's headed
though the only might sold on this kid
the only honest the only part of God of
worth legacy that I looking back I'm not
super happy about is all like the
contextual QuickTime events that I feel
like they weren't the first game to it
but they definitely I think popularized
it a lot more yeah I know it's cool at
the time I think they can still be used
in a good way like when you're doing
things that are beyond your capabilities
in the game normally
it's become a sort of a catch-all for
involving you in cinematics which can
often be boring the worst is when you're
just not paying attention and they jump
Eunice Lee wait what
yeah the first e3 where they showed it
off 2016 you should go back and watch we
did the quarry bar log the creative
director came on stage back when like
Danny was still here and I think I might
have been on stage at that point with
them they talked about how the creative
directors like Owen relationship with
his son is kind of bleeding into it
sounds cool hopefully they can handle it
well but go out back and watch that it's
on GameSpot in YouTube if you want to
check it out for more information all
right
there's been a lot of so many games we
talked about before we get to more games
that actually came out recently last one
from sucker punch ghosts of Tsushima
sucker punch being the team behind the
infamous series and we've been for a
while maybe like a couple years now
people been saying I wonder what they're
up to because they're like an internal
or they've always they've been making
Sony exclusives so long what are they up
to and they showed off ghosts of
Tsushima like what starts off as a just
kind of samurai looking story set in on
the island of Tsushima it became kind of
supernatural toward the end when they
were talking about it like it was a
voiceover bus from there like some sort
of villain talking to the protagonist
goal oh is it like the Mongol invasion
that they're okay you betcha Mike yeah
this looks so sick this reminds me of
neo odd also but that's just probably
because neo has a super like samurai
okay yeah it's a it looks gorgeous but
yeah it's weird it's such a huge jump
from infamous but it is open-world
they're talking about stealth as well
yeah stealth would be a big thing so
still remains to be seen but it looks
promising 20 Hanzo sword so I think my
concern I I didn't play first light
which I heard was much better but second
Sun I thought was mostly just show like
I I didn't think there was a lot of
depth to it I didn't I didn't enjoy it
that much I think I played like four or
five hours and like all right I've seen
my fill I like the first to Memphis
infamous is more but like I'm I'm
curious to see what kind of game this
ends up being apart from just an
open-world exploration game cuz if you
watch the documentary after the thing
was the creative director right just
explaining an open-world the game and it
was like okay this sounds like you
every open-world game so I wonder what
the twist is of the setting which does
look dope that actor just before this
guy looked really familiar but yeah like
here it looks it looks like it has a
supernatural vibe all of a sudden less
that was just like just the editing
itself for the sake of it
but yeah it was it's also interesting to
see what companies are doing with open
world games moving forward after in like
a post breath of the wild not that every
game needs to be compared to it but like
a post breath of the wild horizon was
good but I think horizon was like the
peak of the old open-world design I
would say that's kind of being reductive
but um there may be like it's not the
same as Grand Theft Auto but in terms of
like this looks like it would line up
more with something like horizon rather
than breath of a while but who knows
yeah like like you said Jake second son
felt almost more like it was a showcase
for the ps4 that came out pretty early
in the consoles life cycle not a few
maybe a few months after I played it and
I liked it but it wasn't anything
remarkable especially the protagonist I
don't even remember his name did the
beanie on I don't like him being a boy
[Music]
Daryl I don't know we'll figure it out
but anyway what are you most excited for
from the Paris games week announcements
for Sony Jake uh I mean probably the
Last Guardian I've heard so much about
that game for a long time I've heard so
much about the shadow of Colossus and
I'm very very excited for it also
excited for the Last of Us but kind of
like what we said before I that trailer
didn't exactly get me more excited for
it but yeah about you Rob yeah I think I
totally agree with you because that
trailer for shadow Colossus was was
smart in showing the environments and
like the solitude with that game because
I keep hearing about these bosses right
and they didn't show a single one on
that trailer like that was really great
and and it was it was yeah it was just
really smart to like just capitalize on
like hey like we really spent a lot of
time like every bit of the way I'm
stoked that game - it was Delsin Rowe
Dolson I thought it was some
I think that yeah I played shy of the
Colossus and I think that's still the
one I'm most excited about it also helps
it's coming out soon so it's more
tangible but ghosts of Tsushima I'm
super interested in
I like past stuff sucker punch is done
and that looks like setting and a
character I can get into mmm so see what
about you mm-hmm Detroit right to try a
cool cut this video there you said
Gardens between advance what's called
yeah and of course shadow the closest as
well and ghost of Tsushima but that's
more of like okay you've you've got me
interested Yeah right but we'll see you
don't know much about it yet cool
all right so that's all Sony's new
release date announcements game
announcements whether indie Studios
internal studios look forward next week
to horizon zero dawn in the frozen wilds
will be able talk about next week or
notes coming out next week from gorilla
gorilla games yeah I'm excited
that's a whole new area on the game
right to the open-world game like 15
hours of gameplay is what this guy told
me last night cool bring our private
phone text see I'm really excited for
that because I'm only played like 10
hours of the base game I have to finish
I can't do it yeah is my finish I really
liked it what came out man what came out
what the week after like yeah I know
same problem with the phantom pain
everyone was like yeah I like the 1015
hours I played of it
I finished whatever I'm there with you
yeah but like you're the Jake in this
situation so this is the paid DLC right
yeah blue so the frozen wilds yeah I say
there right yeah that's out next week
we'll talk more about in the lobby
I would assume unless there's an embargo
that I don't know about lobby the
embargo is forget are you you might get
it soon hopefully from from Sony sweet
all right now we're gonna talk for those
joining on YouTube twitch GameSpot we're
actually gonna talk about games that
came out last week that we played a lot
of I'll start with Wolfenstein - I want
to talk about what makes it such a good
shooter because the bullets yeah that
helps there's a lot to talk about and
Kelly's not here she reviewed it which
isn't it's unfortunate that she's not
here she gave it what she did in 9 on
the 10 but it's just a fantastic game
and all it's like a lot of us at the
here in the office are in agreement that
it's good I like it more than the new
order which in itself is an amazing game
as a reboot of the series it was a great
mother machinegames
Swedish studio right did a did a great
job remaking this how long did this take
me it was good recently I kind of went
through guns blazing this whereas I
focus more on stealth in the new order
but on this steam I had about 11 hours
to finish okay how long after the first
game was like several years right just
be or no no this is right after 60 how
about five months jean-luc yes you go to
Nazi occupied America in the 60s and
they kind of go for the whole
counterculture thing especially you pick
Wyatt but anyway that's all the stories
fantastic the characters are great they
introduce new characters who I love I
love super special go too much into any
spoilers obviously we talked about this
last week but it was annoying because
there was we couldn't talk past the
first five chapters and we're not gonna
get into any spoilers we'll make sure
that on the show but we can talk about
the game overall now Jake you did you
finish it yesterday yeah this weekend
Sunday I think and yeah I know you're a
huge fan of the new order how do you
think this compares I think this
improves in almost every way I think
they're super special right there sorry
I think there are some like I thought BJ
blast fits his characterization and the
first one was better but I think they
had to focus more on him because you
know he seems like a meathead everyone's
like okay he's probably not gonna be
that good of a character that's a good
point they really doubled down on that
character development and I thought it
was fantastic character all of the
monologues he had and the first one were
amazing as well and this I mean he's
still a great character but I think this
one focuses on like a broader range of
adding new characters adding more
characterization to previous characters
and then I think overall gameplay is
much better granted I played on ps4 I
think for the first one and PC on this
which was you know it felt like a huge
step but yeah I mean I loved this game
this is easily probably my top 5 mhm
top 10 if not top 5 yeah it's I think
the game struck a much better balance
between like it's bombast and Kinder's
all-out you know Nazi killing like you
said musclehead kind of but also like
the resistance fighting back but also
like it had a lot of more sentimental
moments the first game
had that same dichotomy I would say but
this game straddles that line much
better I think and it feels more natural
oh man this game also just becomes
batshit crazy in so many ways in that
story but also I mean you're watching
he's just like the old game here
dual-wielding but now you can mix and
match weapons you can have a pistol in
one hand the machine pistol in the other
or the assault rifle in one hand and the
try barrel rotating shotgun in the other
I haven't finished it but to hear you
guys talk about how crazy it gets I mean
I think I'm about judging from I'm on
the train here this is actually legit
where I last saw nothing I already feel
like I've seen a lot of crazy [ __ ] these
are new - you just saw them gun upgrades
they also have the perks that you get
for doing certain kills like the thrown
hatchet kills or these stealth kill man
killing a commander before they alert
the rest of the reinforcements and those
perks are still there but now you can
also upgrade weapons and there's like
three upgrades for each weapon I believe
and they're all super useful there's
something to be said about that that
progression system is so appealing to
like to be able to like just the two
combined like straight game play with
progression in the same vein of how you
want to play the game you know what I
mean like if you want to be more
stealthy well you know to have six more
takedowns and and you can Crouch or one
Crouch you can you can walk faster
because I I for one am I playing really
stealth and reserved I just like playing
like that style but ya know totally it's
cool to like to just focus on stuff you
want to focus on like I don't really
care about dual wielding as much despite
this game kind of pushing you to do a
wield you really want to be always
moving and shooting the stuff works at
times but there are set pieces so to
speak we're like nope you cannot stay
put you're moving around they're always
fight they do enemies are always
flanking you oh yeah more than any other
game I feel like I've always had a guy
directly behind me sneaking around well
it's interesting because doom 2016 was
so much about forward movement
specifically and constantly moving and
if your health is low but wanted you to
melee people so you get health
and if your ammo is low it once you -
chainsaw people so you get ammo and then
you would be constantly seeking chainsaw
fuel to keep that loop going this game
is kind of that forward movement and
trying to stay moving because like you
said Rob they're trying to flank you but
it's also you got to know when to take
cover because yeah one complaint I have
about this game the feedback when you're
getting it's a it seems Meyer but you're
getting shot at so much this game I wish
the feedback on it like even in like it
I don't know that I'm losing health so
often and I look down and I have 20
health left and no all right I wish that
was something other than that was the
case yeah like any kind of like I mean
generally most games have like a you
know like a blood-red vignette or
something like that you know I mean like
any indication that you're taking hull
if I can't agree with you it's I do like
it it's old-school like you're actually
picking up health and armor that's
that's [ __ ] that's great yeah and
duman's like that as well right like
yeah I do wish I knew I was getting shot
more and also I you can you can do hard
saves whenever you want I didn't even
know this until later in the game until
like the last fight that it was actually
a hard saving when just go back to the
checkpoint John Luke told me what the
[ __ ] yeah one nice thing I'm playing on
PC is you just hit f5 yeah I mean it's
pretty yeah it's pretty fast on console
as well if you just you have to manually
do it but it takes a little bit longer
but I thought there were some some
spikes in the difficulty that hurt the
pacing but if I had been saving doing
hard saves the whole time maybe I
wouldn't it was mind it as much better
than that yeah it's a tough game and I
feel like it earns it I'm looking
forward to maybe over the holidays or
something when I have more time going
back picking Fergus as opposed to why it
as my supporting character that you
could choose they you go back you make a
choice from the first game right the
beginning of this and yeah and I love
the setting maybe it's just because it's
kind of this not even post-apocalyptic
but it might as well be nazi-occupied
America you're gonna New Orleans New
York Roswell it's great there's a
there's a cool thing too that I I mean I
didn't even know about I don't think a
lot of people knew about until later at
least in the office was that those
enigma codes you get you can unlock side
missions that lets you return to other
areas and kind of do in like that that's
really cool that's pretty substantial to
like it adds a good level of replay
value and I noticed like I kind of hate
bring this up but I noticed a lot of
like in the steam reviews it's like 6
hours of gameplay four hours of
cutscenes like I don't wanna play a game
like this and it's like well there's all
those side quests that you can do and
they're actually pretty fun to unlock
with those
enigma codes also those cutscenes yeah
every single one of them good like but
the cutscenes did flush some are like so
like the best choreograph comparisons
like inglourious basterds but in this
game I think that holds even more weight
there are several scenes in this where
you're in control of BJ but you're in
the scene and it's it is it's scripted
so well and it's tensest book it's
really good like I know I've talked
about in the office but in one of the
demos that we played beforehand they
showed that scene where BJ meets with
the grassroots resistance yeah where
he's like he's like I don't do my own
horn except literally a clarinet player
playing jazz in the background the
cameras just spinning around their
conversation as they're having this like
really battle of whit's it's so good
this guy reminded me of Mad Max like how
the music they're playing becomes part
of the soundtrack yeah or like a burden
man yeah exactly yeah I was just to say
like and not even in just the cutscenes
I think I think this game really handled
V like more like a the in game like when
you're on like your your sub for
instance and you're kind of walking
around and you're running into like
people interacting with each other all
of those are orchestrated and polished
really well we're like I feel like so
many times I've seen games or like
moments where you can just hear the
brakes and dialogue or like choreography
where it's like it's segmented and it
doesn't have that refined like if I'm
cutting you like for instance if I'm
gonna cut off your dialogue right that
needs to be me cutting off and
overlapping your vo right and like I
don't know just like the polish of like
seeing people interact with each other
is so satisfying and there's everything
has so much weight and like to even
mention inglorious basterds again
because there is I feel like a lot of
that vibe but like I feel like it pushes
in many scenes like pushes the
boundaries a little farther it was like
the weight and the the gravity of like
so many themes of their hand
they're dealing with uh yeah can we
finish it but as a shooter this game is
just fantastic it feels great and like
the how gritty and heavy and like almost
like just like messy the shooting is
make sense for BJ and just he's an angry
character so you're just flooding dude
doing dual shotguns down a hallway when
there's like six dad in front you don't
even at the aim you shoot especially you
get to ricochet upgrade it's most
satisfying feeling in the world yeah and
I think as a shooter this game I think
the first game was great about
encouraging stealth or combat but I
think it relied too often on just
sandbox after sandbox after sandbox and
that can be great but I feel like it was
a little row at that point this one I
think knows when to ease up on that and
give you these corridors where you can
actually go down like sneak around in
these internal areas I think it's very
good at choreographing some of these
fights and then letting you loose in
these smaller environments to fight
these these mechs or to survive this way
or to stell through this way uh I think
this game is much better at a aside from
those difficulty spikes think it's
better pacing than the new order and the
new order I think too often relied on
here's your objective like freeing these
people from prison that part was awesome
that was really fun but again I think
new Colossus knows when to get out of
your way in a great way and if it feels
great it some of the I think it's great
in the way you're actually come up to
these breather kind of climb action
against these what could be just this
dumb mech boss fight and I'm not saying
something like that doesn't because I'm
not saying it does but instead they
could put you up against like just a
horde of new kind of like mechanized
enemies or the enemy variety is great
too like the dogs can come rushing at
you and you're meanwhile trying to kill
this commander but also there's a Panzer
heleng2 coming around the corner it's
gonna breathe fire on you yeah I kinda
agree if you'd like not to say that like
the first order was was more linear but
there are moments that I've had so far
in new Colossus were like the games
clearly telling me like for instance in
like New York it's telling me to like go
down is the subway and I was like let's
do a little more exploring and like an
enemy popped out that I felt like I
would not have run into
had I gone down the path that they laid
out like I felt like there were a lot of
moments where my choice like had an
impact in the game and that was a
rewarding yeah main last thoughts and
Wolfenstein 2 you play much of it yet
now you've been focus I would be talking
if I had played dynamic come on
- little bit but I'm just saying like I
didn't want to exclude you completely I
know you've been busy with Mario and now
you got horizon so yeah place game my
last thought is like this game is so
freakin funny and sad it's that and it's
yeah it's it's an it's definitely a
roller coaster but like funny I love
when people can like knock out of the
park with like jokes and stuff like god
there's there's yeah I love it when like
you're talkin BJ and Anya are talking
over the radio oh yeah and then they say
something kind of intimates Anya being
is the one there they're both they have
twins on the way and they say something
intimate and then someone like this
channel public they're like is someone
else on this channel they're like yes
Mac sauce yeah Mac sauce kind of like
the Hodor games fantastic it's one of my
it's one of the more not surprising I
think I expected quality out of machine
games with this considering the new
order in the old blood if you played two
standalone DLC it kind of goes back
chronologically before both of these I
think they made you rage the
environments a great shooter in its own
right it feels great it's tough in a
good way
for the most part aside from some spikes
but it's got hard save and it's
forgiving enough when it needs to be I
want to play on uber the hardest
difficulty and taking 30 days to
complete it'd be fun though yeah all
right cool now did you play a March
Super Mario Odyssey like I'd be taught
oh yes I did reduce something to a score
but you gave this game a 10 out of 10 on
a game spot which means it is essential
to the central game so if you're
watching this or somehow coming across
the video you should play Super Mario
I've see if you have any passing
interest in video games
and if you have a switch yeah walk me
through it what where's why is this such
a great 3d platformer when when when
Mario is known for these with Super
Mario 64 Super Mario Galaxy games
tomorrow sunshine you know I don't
really like well it's very different
from all those games despite sort of
having the same general 3d platformer
premise and more than anything Super
Mario de si is a is a playground for
discovery and you know the whole deal is
like you're collecting moons and and in
the past maybe you would set out in
certain levels to like collect a star
and you get sent back to the beginning
like this game like can you find one
moon you continue the next one and if
you're you're really aware what you're
doing and you're really away
Mario is capable of and that includes
how he can use his environments and
enemies to his advantage you can find a
moon and thus feel rewarded like every
other minute and when you're doing that
you're also going through like you know
these environments that seem somewhat
small like on paper but once you're
actually moving and shaking within them
there's so much to see and do and it
just it just feels sort of like a
never-ending never-ending like hunt for
these things and discovery for what the
game has that you maybe you didn't see
immediately this game is just like
playing with your endorphins as you're
getting like a moon or coins or purple
coins or finding some sort of secret
every like 30 seconds I feel right and
you're using that to go to open up new
world have to get a new outfit for Mario
you know no you good no you go
I wasn't say but that endorphin like
[ __ ] I don't know that was a moon dude
there are so many like you just you just
can't even begin to spoil it like what I
wasn't saying is that you know not that
it's a bad thing but like as the game
progresses and you you know you you get
past that main quests like those
endorphins are still there but like you
find yourself like really kind of
working a lot more harder to get these
moons like they come they do open up a
new set of moons and they literally tell
you where they are
yeah but then it's yes like after that
which is sort of the post game and then
the real post game yeah because you
could beat the game with what is it 250
moons I think it's like like someone did
a speedrun recently in like 80 something
minutes I think they have about 90 moons
should I have a I think I have more than
that I'm only on the snow Kingdom right
now yeah I mean as you can have more
than that yeah so the game basically
shows you like okay we need this many
moons to power your ship to get to the
next Kingdom and once you visit every
Kingdom then you kind of get to the end
and you can get there pretty quickly if
you just sort of follow the required
moon counts and then proceed to your
next step but you know I beat the game
with like 150 moons and there were seven
nine by 700 left for me to find I'm
currently at 520 ish and that's sort of
like the last big milestone the game
sets for you
five hundred so I'm beyond that at this
point but I'm still enjoying the game
and I'm still you know playing it every
now and then I did put in like like
forty to fifty hours and just like four
days or something like that three or
four days so it was kind of a lot for a
minute but it's it says a lot that I can
keep going back to this game and I don't
really tire of it yeah I think our
friend over at Giant Bomb Dan Reicher
found all the moons correct well friend
I guess but yeah he went pretty crazy on
this game ham that's very like him to do
that alright so let me ask you this
before you guys had finished or at least
before you had gotten up to like the 600
or sorry like 400 or something moons
you're saying a lot of it is easy
maybe that's beside the point but I do
want to talk about the difficulty cuz
I'm finding it is very easy overall and
I'm not like especially great at
platformers I'm pretty decent at this
game but it's obviously it's very
inventive it's very creative it just
kind of like plays your imagination and
what you can think of these environments
but that's the challenge right and also
but there are there are some platforming
parts where you're going through those
cap doors and then getting on those
rockets to launch into space for those
harder platforming sections did you feel
the difficulty was uh was like well
tailored throughout yeah and I actually
think there's a much bigger discussion
that we should have here which is sort
of the opposite of what I think everyone
was talking about a couple weeks ago
like difficult games are great in their
own way well so are games that are that
are very forgiving and easy in a sense
like I think Mario is the perfect
argument for why both types of games can
exist like yeah even if you fail in the
sections that you're talking about
you're not actually losing much except
for the time you spent to die like end
point you can easily get back
yeah like the coins are so easy to get
and even when you run out of coins and
total like there's no such thing as a
game over in this screen that doesn't
exist there's no 1up mushroom there's no
lives as it were like this is abandoned
anything that made Mario is sort of like
if you can call it that like a
threatening experience where you can put
so much time and energy into something
and then not get there and have to start
a whole kingdom or world over mhm
and just feel like man that's really
frustrating does that mean this game is
bad because it's easy I would say no
unless you you need to prove something
or you can only enjoy to
forkel games like this game can be
surprisingly difficult when it comes to
the puzzle solving which is really how
you use mario and the environment to
acquire the moon that you can see but
you're like how the hell do I get to it
so it can be surprisingly challenging in
those ways towards the very end of the
game you do unlock some stuff that is
sort of like a gauntlet where if you die
no there's no checkpoint you have to go
back to the beginning and that takes the
form of a boss rush and is a really
difficult series of platforming sections
and in that sense it seems to harken
back to something like mario 64 where it
is so much about the platforming and
really a test of your skill this is more
a test of your strategizing and
execution in so many ways even like met
your ability to switch up your
perspective which I think kind of helps
in this game yeah yeah there are there
are certain times where it helps to
really like line it up in like a 2d
perspective and not just the retro
sections but like even when 3d
platforming or go to a top-down
perspective as well and even just
challenging yourself to always change
the camera angle in your perspective
because that's the only way you can find
all the moons and that's the only way
towards the end of the game that you can
really make progress but that also makes
these seemingly small open worlds that
much more interesting because no matter
where you look you will ultimately be
facing something that is worth seeking
it's and it's yeah and and coming back
with a different perspective like a lot
of times I've run into that where like
I've spent a lot of time on a little
mini game Mike you saw me battling one
the other day and it's forgiving in the
sense where it's like you know what I'm
just gonna come back because there's so
much to do in this playground as a whole
that I have no problem walking away from
things and that's where the challenge is
like is it's bearable in my perspective
is just like yeah just a Kyle come back
it's not problem there's so much going
on I can I can get more moons somewhere
else but you can you can pretty much get
any moon right from the start if you
know where it is and how to like handle
your environment Marius outfits don't
give him any special powers it's the nez
capture and they're limited to these
environments and you can't take them out
so you've got all the tools you need to
get the moon's
pretty much unless I'm forgetting I
would say like some of the worlds
you'd have to defeat a specific boss to
like get open up new areas to moons like
sure something like ability wise you're
right yeah yeah there's anything
speaking of abilities and whatnot so
he's got a pretty diverse skill set in
this game one thing that people were
worried about was like maybe in a
reliance on motion controls was that the
case here did you entirely option I
think that's been blown out of
proportion half to the review there's a
couple moves cuz Mario can throw his hat
obviously he can throw his hat in a few
different ways some of those extra ways
you can manage through button presses
other ones you have to use motion
controls in handheld mode throwing your
hat up or down isn't great and I don't
even know if it works to be honest with
you I've been able to do it properly
mostly cuz I don't want to like fling my
entire switch up and down holding it by
the controllers but the only times where
I had to do that was when there it was
like a couple moons I was like okay
clearly I need to shake to get my hat up
there because I can't jump that high so
I pop the joint cons off my switch and
his did it and put him back on it was
like 20 seconds over and done with if
you have a pro controller you can do
everything that you could with the joy
Commons so yeah there are a couple
forced motion controls things in here
that's not great like no one loves to be
forced to do that especially when it
seems like it probably could have found
a way to do it with buttons but it's
certainly not like an issue no well yeah
there are some the spin attack so if
you're using the joy cons you flick both
joy cons to either side simultaneously
but if you're playing on handle you or
even on a regular troll you could just
also rotate the left stick right or you
do it kind of like in the older Zelda 3d
games you could either charge with B or
you know spin the stick and that works
with a programmed trailer it feels super
natural because you basically just like
you let go of one side of it hold to the
other handle and just sort of flick your
wrist it feels like you're throwing a
frickin hat yeah in a sense
and so it yeah and in that respect it is
you know a split second as far as the
timing right like it is feasibly quicker
to do this than it is to do that spin
move right because that that's been
moved where the Hat circle circles you
is actually pretty vital like for a lot
of scenarios as far as like help
protection helpful I don't vital is
taking it too far because the game never
requires it of you it Vactor presents it
as like an efficiency thing yes and
that's what I was gonna say with like
that moon now you're talking about that
you couldn't get with the hath row yeah
I wouldn't say like there is always a
way
around that always like I've never had
the need where it's like I cannot get
here
or grab this with without there are in
mine there are definitely a couple moons
we really you had to do that you had
that problem where it's confirmed
yeah and it's a thing it's all spin move
no there's another one like the Frog if
you shake the controller the Frog does
an extra flip and will jump a little bit
higher unless you do that
what can you describe it that's I can't
there's also the sorry there's also the
moon I think it's in the wooded Kingdom
where there's these it's it's called a
weird strange neighborhood and the the
platforms are moving like apartments and
you have to go back and stack all the
goombas I don't think you can make some
of those jumps without shaking it
because the goombas jump much higher
when you try it as opposed to just the
hop so I could definitely see me I don't
the moon I'm thinking of particular
maybe it's a dream you bail with other
people I don't think I could have done
it without the shake jump with the
Goomba stack goombas I could be wrong
though but not to your point I can see
that being the case where some moons
where you would need there's only two
that I can really think of where shaking
is required one of them's a napkin him
one and there's another one that I'd
forget where it was but yeah but it is
interesting you talk about how this game
kind of challenges your imagination in
terms of what you how you see the levels
because I think Mario Galaxy when it
came out was much more about those
smaller sand boxes and also being kind
of creative with how they used three oh
yeah there's a lot of like those
spherical worlds and I think both games
play with a 3d level design in an
awesome way
I mean Mario 64 didn't that's a
precedence forever but I didn't I don't
I'm not a huge fan of sunshine maybe I
need to go back to it I know that game
has it's a lot of defenders for people
who aren't super stoked on it's just a
lot of people like that game but I loved
the Mario Galaxy games and I think this
game kind of continues that legacy of 3d
marios playing with level design in a
cool way to your point it's very much
every time I go into a world I see it
like an aesthetic level and then I know
there's a ton that's gonna unfold before
me yeah I mean some of these places have
over 100 moons yeah well maybe just one
I can think of but yeah like that gets
that high I mean I was I spent like
maybe five hours in toast arena town or
not the town what was the desert Kingdom
yeah but wait toast around town in it
steam gardens what were you saying
I love that song
would you say this I'm not asking you
for a definitive ranking or list but say
we go so 3d Mario games Mario 64 Super
Mario Sunshine Mario Galaxy 1 and 2 and
if you want to do like 3d world and 3d
Land and factor those in where does this
fit on that list is it's up there yeah I
mean it's up there and I can only speak
to my personal experience but it's I
find it really hard to compare all those
games because yeah they have Mario and
they have some other consistent things
but they're all very different at their
core they all offer very different takes
on 3d platforming again despite the
similarities you see between them
but you know if I if you put all of them
in front of me right now I you know I
think I'd probably play Mario 64 in this
the galaxy games are really like
sunshine didn't really do it for me
3d Land is interesting 3d world was a
little too messy with the multiplayer
stuff it wasn't required but I felt like
the game really it shined for that in
some ways but it also didn't succeed in
that way but if you talk about
multiplayer with this game as well capi
is an autonomous being like you don't
have to just be the second player
flicking the controller and that's it
you can separate from our his head and
go and do your own [ __ ] and troll Mario
if you want to as well I mean the
gameplay conceit of taking over other
creatures alone is enough that makes
this game fun even outside the level
design I mean they're showing in the the
wooded Kingdom I don't even know what
they are the sprouts that those are the
seeds that sprout the legs they go
they're so funny you held up roots and
then those caterpillars in the Lost
Kingdom that you stretch they're so fun
to use and Rob you said this is the
first time a while you've played a
platforming game where like you never
felt like the game was working against
you like you said like it makes such
good confidence in your precision oh
well yeah like there there was one
moment where it was a little in the
luncheon Kingdom where like yeah this is
just doing the multiplayer I actually
people were kind of ragging on this I
thought the two player to be pretty fun
I don't know I don't know how long I
mean I'd feel like I'd had to play more
but like for what it is and what it
could have been like it could have been
just like a tacked on like you know here
press a and you can like launch copy and
that's all you do as a second player
like you have a lot of control and I
think if you worked really well with
someone like you could do some like you
can do some moves that like
think we're not you weren't able to in
like by yourself right like like you'd
be you can be both like tasks at the
same time like I can be like getting
coins as Peters like you know jumping
around stopping on goombas or some like
that it was it was neat to see those
work stacking goombas is so fun yeah it
feels great yeah but I would say there's
a moment where like I so many
platforming games where you're you there
is a fear right like when you when
you're dealing with ultra precise
platforms you're trying to jump on and
land sometimes they're just these
moments and games where it's like you
know that the controller or the the
movement is ultra sensitive and you just
you have that like second-guess and you
fall off there are times we're like you
know platforms raising and lowering
we're like when lowered the area of that
I can step on is ultra small like I feel
like any other game I would have like
seen I'm like no I'm gonna wait I'm
gonna wait like that two three seconds
before I jump but like this game it was
like no I can totally I can totally nail
it and that happened like time and time
again where I was doing like pretty what
felt risky moves but just fully aware
that I can I can do anything like is it
is so natural and seamless like
controlling Mario also like one of the
happiest games I've ever seen like AI
nigma theory and in the twitch chat was
saying yeah the difficulty isn't in the
platform in South the porting game it's
all about finding all these collectables
and exploring and that's if you want to
consider it that difficult that's how it
fits in this game and like you were just
saying that fits I don't think very very
brutal platforming would fit within what
this game is going for it well the the
sections they add in feel good because
they are sort of some of the only
distinct levels we're like you enter a
pipe or a door and you end up in a
different place you're not really on the
map of the open world anymore so it
segments those sections from the main
game and I think it works especially
because they tend to come after you've
beaten the story the first time well not
the first time you beat the first major
storyline before moving on to what's
left if you will also this scene is a
pretty good exam
of how this game is so freakin strange I
laugh so hard at this scene where you
just seen sheeple just going from one
door to the next like what are they
doing why is there like a meat factory
they're like falling into like it's all
instead of a building there is a food
factory in this town oh yeah I just
wanted to take those moons yeah that was
this is the first thing they showed off
right that you actually go to like a
real world not just the Mushroom Kingdom
yeah but sorry I'm just realizing the
moon Factory established as why you can
just buy moons at the store oh my god go
[ __ ] right lure busted or no lure
confirm I don't know myth busted nice
alright anyway sorry Jake what I was
just gonna say one of the most
satisfying like possessions that I've
found or it's it's pretty obvious you'll
come across but that woodpecker yet that
like stick in and then cuz I love that
mechanic and all totally clicking the
stick and even you pokeo ores when you
combine that it's so much fun yeah yeah
and the same goes for the Metro Kingdom
New York City just like the verticality
of all the buildings and all those poles
there's such joy and like you know I
think they're called pylons spark pylons
where you just you're zipping around
you're in midair clinging to a pole
flicking up chasing a rabbit like it's
so rewarding just to like control Mario
and just run around that game like you
get so distracted it's great it does a
really good job of distilling I think I
don't want to say what makes video games
great as a whole but it really does sort
of give you a game that controls really
well makes you happy to be in its world
presents challenges but then doesn't
actually punish you for going out of
your comfort zone trying to get them
yeah super mario super i zoom in play
the game tangle I have one yeah
i reviews up on GameSpot you know read
Pete's review though see on YouTube it
is it's up there for your eyeholes go
check it out it's a great game one of
the three great games we talked about
Sanskrit I've fallen in love with that
game over the weekend we don't really
have much time but uh to play Sanskrit
origins too we also gave that a good
review cool as always we have a giveaway
Call of Duty World War 2 released this
Friday a few of us here are playing it
but in the meantime here is the giveaway
it's a poster collection there are 40
posters in there from past Call of Duty
games and also including World War two
there's a moleskin notebook up there up
front and some sort of Field Manual
artbook kind of see that field no it's
actually really cool I am I'm not really
one to pimp giveaways but the amount of
detail went into I feel many someone
like basically it's all like rustled in
like aged paper flood uh there's like
pained photos with like actual paper
clips it's like really neat as far as
the aesthetic of like its if it feels
like an old manual like okay I imagine
someone taking the all these pages and
like crumpling them and then straighten
them out yeah like they really want the
town on that I just want to say that was
cool yeah call do a twirl or two
releases Friday the embargo like
Thursday or release or what today damn
that's two days away [ __ ] miguel
concepción is reviewing that right he's
in Japan but I think he's reviewed it
already I don't know when we're putting
it up can you talk about it or no this
being quite as you keep talking yeah
it's a I will keep talk tomorrow
tomorrow cool you have this bit can you
talk about the time I could if I could
remember okay tomorrow we'll have our
call to meet one more to review up from
sledgehammer games former visceral guys
sad to say that that studio is closed
down
but Glenn Scofield Michael Condrey are
doing well because this game looks good
yeah so that giveaway as always if you
don't follow GameSpot Twitter go do so
and then retweet said giveaway tweet
will be picking winners throughout the
week you could be one of them
we have our fourth camera on the back
room correct jean-luc waiting for him to
play yes can you transfer to that camera
quick you don't mind oh so there he is
John who fray in the middle he's pretty
pissed back to him there's Eric Tay and
Richard Lee and our back room as always
yeah no 39 thank you rigidly erect a and
birthday boy jean-luc in the back room
and also jean-luc and Eric kind of
announced it yesterday on their a
destiny stream but as always and I get
brought up the beginning to show [ __ ]
extra life November 17th starting at
noon pacific
here are these terrible pictures of all
of us we're gonna be bouncing between
the US UK and Australia throughout that
weekend kind of right before the
American Thanksgiving so that'll be fun
we're gonna be playing some multiplayer
games doing some dumb that's I'm sure to
raise some money for a charity
presumably it started off for for ill
children so see if we can continue that
trend and raise some money this year
Rob's gonna hold that face for 72 hours
not shifted on you but you look like you
like we're taking a mug shot I'm sure
probably was cool so that'll be and yeah
Dvorak on twitch was just saying the
minecraft server we always have a
minecraft server where people build
stuff there only gets to go back someone
else I think yeah usually used to set up
a will do it I think yeah someone had
mentioned me it do and it will
definitely figure how to bring it back
oh you have contacted us it should be it
will be done
What did he say they have contacted us
it will be done oh cool yeah we'll have
a minecraft server for those asking for
those who don't know we just kind of
people fans build just cool stuff
throughout the weekend and we go into it
and explore what they've been doing
sometimes it's amazed and they'll go in
and rearrange it while we're going
through it the [ __ ] with us it's fun so
that'll be a long weekend but fun
weekend for a worthwhile cause as always
thanks for joining us the lobby every
Wednesday at 11 a.m. Pacific we'll be
back next week talking crawl call duty
World War 2 Battlefront we'll be right
on the horizon don't think I'll be able
to talk too much about battlefront 2 yet
but uh yeah maybe we'll talk about
stranger things season 2 Eisen and
horizons DLC Thank You frozen wilds but
as always we'll see you next week and in
the meantime stay tuned the game spot
late row
[Music]